I think there if there are some
interesting cases where people get it
wrong and we know why they got it wrong
and this is this often occurs in the
case when you have very distinctive
items and so this is one of the things
that once you kind of get expert at it
you've got to watch out for because it
because as I said with what we're
looking for is we're looking for
patterns we're looking for overall
patterns and things that are distinctive
by by nature of being distinct that
they're they're inconsistent with the
pattern but they draw your attention so
we went into one of the rooms we went
into everything indicated it was a
socially responsible person who was a
nice person they were organized and
together and not that reckless we're
pretty sort of conservative in many ways
yet in the corner of the room there was
a plastic crate full of drug
paraphernalia you know a bong for
smoking marijuana and stuff like that
and of course the judge has come in and
they see that which sticks out and they
go straight over to it and are likely to
interpret it you know make draw strong
inferences from it of course the very
reason that makes it stick out is the
very reason they should have ignored it
and it turns out when I later found out
what was what what was it doing there
turns out that this person was holding
on to the roommate had gone traveling
around the world how could you look
after the stuffs good yeah sure upper
and she put it responsibly put it in a
crate and put it in the corner of the
room so you know it was it is it was
consistent with above Manny but not in
the way you think